SCREW AND THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
AND DAMAGE ON SO MANY LEVELS.
AARON MET -- AARON MATE,
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: THIS DISASTER AND
IT WAS A DISASTER NOT JUST
POLITICALLY BUT INTERNATIONALLY
CHANGED OUR RUSSIAN POLICY AS A
RESULT OF THIS HOAX.
WENT ON AS LONG AS IT DID
BECAUSE PRETTY MUCH NO ONE IN
WASHINGTON TRIED TO PUT THE
BRAKES ON.
I DON’T WANT TO POINT FINGERS
ARE ANYTHING BUT FOR ALL OF 2017
AND 2018, REPUBLICANS CONTROLLED
BOTH HOUSES OF CONGRESS.
TREY GOWDY WAS THERE WITH THE
HOUSE COMMITTEE.
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON TONIGHT.
I THINK THAT THIS WAS, AND I
JUST SET IT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING, DRIVEN BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
BUT IT WAS ALLOWED TO
METASTASIZE BECAUSE THE
REPUBLICAN-CONTROLLED CONGRESS
DID NOT STOP IT.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
>> WELL, TWO THINGS.
LET ME JUST SAY, YOU REFERENCE
SUSAN RICE.
SHE NEEDED TO READ THE REST OF
THAT EMAIL BUT YOU CAN’T BECAUSE
IT HASN’T BEEN DECLASSIFIED.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT PRESIDENT OBAMA
KNEW AND WHAT ROLE HE PLAYED,
YOU NEED TO READ AND ACCESS THE
REST OF SUSAN RICE’S EMAIL AND
HOPEFULLY, IT WILL BE
DECLASSIFIED ONE DAY AND YOU
CAN.
FOR RUSSIA, I THOUGHT
DEVIN NUNES DID A PHENOMENAL
JOB.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID.
WE WILL FIND OUT WHAT RUSSIA
DID, WITH WHOM WITH ANYONE THEY
DID IT AND HOW TO MAKE SURE THEY
DON’T DO IT AGAIN IN 2020 AND
THEN THE ISSUE OF UNMASKING AND
UNLEASH.
AND SO THERE WERE THINGS HE
WANTED US TO LOOK AT.
NOBODY GAVE A DAMN ABOUT THREE
OF THEM.
ALL THEY CARED ABOUT IS WITH
WHOM ANY ONE.
60, 70 WITNESS INTERVIEWS AND
THAT MUCH OR MORE AND TEN WE
BOB MUELLER.
LOOK, IN MY DEFENSIVE OF
DEVIN NUNES?
I AM BECAUSE HE HAD A DIFFICULT
2017.
HE WRAPPED UP HIS INVESTIGATION
A LOT QUICKER THAN POPULAR WITH
A LOT LESS HELP FROM THE
WITNESSES.
>> Tucker: OAK MIGHT THINK
THAT IS RIGHT.
I THINK THE SCARIEST PART OF ALL
OF THIS IS THE BEHAVIOR OF THE
FBI THE MOST POWERFUL IN THE
WORLD.
BUT IT IS SINISTER WHAT THEY DID
TO MICHAEL FLYNN.
YOU WERE BRIEFED BY THE FBI IN
2018 AND SHORTLY AFTER THAT
BRIEFING CAME ON THIS CHANNEL TO
DESCRIBE YOUR REACTION TO IT.
HERE IS WHAT YOU SAID THEN.
>> BUT AS OF NOW, I THINK CHRIS
RAY AND ROSENSTEIN ARE STUNNED
WHENEVER PEOPLE THINK TRUMP ARE
THE TARGET OF THE INVESTIGATION.
I WILL LEAVE IT UP TO THEM HOW
TO BRIEF THE PRESIDENT.
>> THAT POINT OF VIEW THAT YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW, WAS
THAT STRENGTH AND GOING INTO
THIS BRIEFING LAST WEEK?
>> YES, I AM MORE CONVINCED THE
FBI DID EXACTLY WHAT MY FELLOW
CITIZENS WOULD WANT THEM TO DO
WHEN THEY GOT THE INFORMATION
THEY GOT, AND IT HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH DONALD TRUMP.
>> Tucker: I REMEMBER WATCHING
THAT AND THINKING, BOY, I HOPE
HE IS RIGHT.
DO YOU STILL FEEL THAT WAY?
>> UP GOSH, NO.
I MADE A LOT OF MISTAKES IN
LIFE.
RELYING ON BRIEFINGS AND NOT
INSISTING ON THE DOCUMENTS.
IT TOOK ME ABOUT THREE WEEKS.
I WENT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
I SAT THERE FOR FOUR HOURS.
THAT IS WHEN I SAW PETER STRZOK
PETER STRZOK ACTUALLY INITIATED
AND APPROVED CROSSFIRE
HURRICANE.
THAT IS WHEN I SOLD EXCULPATORY
INFORMATION ON GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS.
THAT IS WHEN I SAW FOR THE VERY
FIRST TIME THAT IT WAS THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN MENTIONED IN THAT
PREDICATE DOCUMENT.
THEY HAD BEEN TELLING US ALL
ALONG TRUMP IS NOT THE TARGETS.
THE CAMPAIGN IS NOT THE TARGET
SO YES, MY MISTAKE WAS RELYING
ON THE WORD OF THE FBI AND THE
DOJ AND NOT INSISTING ON THE
DOCUMENTS.
LUCKILY IT TOOK ME THREE WEEKS
TO CORRECT THAT MISTAKE.
>> Tucker: SO THAT WAS IN
MARCH, JULY WHICH OF COURSE MANY
MONTHS LATER, YOU SAID OF THE
INVESTIGATION IT IS NOT A
WITCH HUNT.
YOU SAID POINTBLANK, IT IS NOT A
BUT IF -- BUT OF COURSE IT WAS A
WITCH HUNT BY DEFINITION.
WHEN DID THAT DAWN ON YOU?
>> TUCKER IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE
FOUR POINTS NUMBER ONE WHAT DID
RUSSIA DO?
I AM CONVINCED THAT RUSSIA TRIED
TO INTERFERE WITH THE
FUNDAMENTALS OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
POINT NUMBER ONE, WHAT DID
RUSSIA DO, NUMBER TWO WITH HIM
IF ANYONE?
I WAS DOWN THERE FOR ALMOST
EVERY WITNESS INTERVIEW AND I
ASKED THE QUESTION AND THE
ANSWER IS NO ONE WITH THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN DID ANYTHING WITH
RUSSIA.
THEN WE GOT TO THE UNMASKING.
SO I DON’T THINK ASKING WHAT DID
RUSSIA DO TO THE COUNTRY IN 2016
OR TRIED TO DO COME I DON’T
THINK THAT WAS A WITCH HUNT.
>> Tucker: BUT WE DON’T HAVE
EVIDENCE THAT THEY DID ATTACK
THE DNC SERVERS OR
JOHN PODESTA’S EMAILS.
SO HOW EXACTLY DID RUSSIA SKEW
THE ELECTION OR INTERFERE ANY
MORE THAN A DOZEN OTHER
COUNTRIES TRIED TO INTERFERE
EVERY DAY?
I’M TOTALLY CONFUSED.
>> NO, I THINK THOSE ARE TWO
SEPARATE INQUIRIES.
I DON’T THINK THEY IMPACTED THE
RESULTS OF THE IMPACT DON’T LIKE
THE ELECTION AT ALL.
DONALD TRUMP WON FAIR AND
SQUARE.
THE SENATE WROTE A REPORT.
I DON’T THINK, THERE IS NOT MUCH
ON THE INTELLIGENCE OF DID
RUSSIA TRY TO INTERFERE.
>> BE WHEN THERE IS WITH ME,
THERE IS WITH ME.
LOTS OF COUNTRIES INTERFERE ALL
THE TIME.
I WANT TO KNOW, IS THERE ANY
EVIDENCE THAT THEY HACKED THE
DNC SERVER.
THAT IS A CENTRAL ALLEGATION AND
WE ARE HEARING, THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE.
AND SO I DON’T KNOW WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT.
>> WELL, WE COULDN’T ANSWER THAT
BECAUSE REMEMBER THE FBI DID NOT
GAIN ACCESS TO THAT SERVER.
THEY DIDN’T EVEN TRY TO GAIN
ACCESS TO THE SERVER.
BUT THE DNC GAVE IT TO CROWD
STRIKE AND WE WILL NEVER KNOW
THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION.
I THINK WHETHER OR NOT TO SOW
SEEDS OF DISCORD I THINK OUR
REPORT DID A GOOD JOB OF
OUTLINING THAT YES, THEY DID
SPECIFIC REFERENCE TO THE DNC.
I ASKED THAT QUESTION.
I DON’T KNOW THAT ANYONE
CONNECTED RUSSIA WITH THE
HACKING OF THE DNC OR IF THEY
DID, I CAN’T RECALL IT.
>> Tucker: EVERYONE DID.
MANY REPUBLICANS DID IT TURNS